Speaker 1: OK, so we're winding down our CPAC
coverage, we'll talk a little bit more about
it at the end of the show.
But the sort of important thing that comes
out of CPAC, the Conservative Political Action
Conference, every year we get closer to an
election, it becomes more relevant is the
CPAC straw poll where attendees vote as to
who they would like to see or approve of in
terms of the next presidential nominee.
And as it turns out, Donald Trump is still
very much in control of the Republican Party.
CNN report Trump wins that CPAC straw poll
as attendees clamor for him to run again.
Former President Donald Trump bathed in the
adulation of an adoring crowd at CPAC Sunday
as he easily won the informal straw poll of
attendees when they were asked who they'd
like to see run for the White House in twenty,
twenty four.
Let's go to a video of CPAC announcing the
results when Trump is included and the results
when Trump is not included.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 5: First one we're going to do is
without Donald Trump.
This is the scenario where he says, no, I'm
not going to run.
Speaker 3: Tell us what it looks like, fellas.
Go ahead, Ryan.
Rhonda, saneness, 68 percent.
Secretary Pompeya with five and Donald Trump
junior four, and now let's take a
Speaker 5: look at what it looks like when
Donald Trump is in the race for 2024.
Speaker 3: Are we ready?
Seventy percent.
It was knocked out just 21 percent.
Go ahead.
All right, and finally, we asked an approval
question
Speaker 5: of Donald Trump across the conference,
there was very, very little disagreement.
With a 98 percent approval rating for Donald
Trump.
Speaker 1: OK, so really no big surprise there.
We were of the impression that Trump was still
completely in control of the Republican Party.
And he clearly seems to be when you include
him, he easily wins the straw poll.
How much of that is people who are just excited
by his celebrity and Trump being there?
Yeah, maybe to some degree there are some
of them.
The other steady component is that Ron DeSantis
seems to be very clearly out ahead of the
rest of the pack as a possible second place
contender, someone who I mean, listen, if
he tried to fight Trump for the nomination,
I don't know what would happen, because much
of the Sanders's support comes from the fact
that he is seen as Trump adjacent and that
Donald Trump has generally been very supportive
of Ron DeSantis.
If Donald Trump didn't run and particularly
if Trump didn't run and said support Ron DeSantis,
the numbers right now to me suggest run Santurce
would be a pretty clear favorite if it's not
Trump for the twenty twenty four Republican
nomination.
Now, as I've said before, I think this is
extraordinarily dangerous.
Why is it dangerous?
As I've said before, if you say assume that
the president will be a Republican, who would
you like it to be?
And in those cases, I've typically said, well,
if it has to be a Republican, I would lean
towards somebody like Mitt Romney.
Mitt Romney's no great guy.
I don't agree with him about a bunch of stuff,
but he's at least sort of like on this planet.
And I know people will say, David, oh, what
are you talking about?
Romney's horrible.
Yeah, Romney's horrible.
But if the question is Romney or Trump, I'm
going with Romney or in the past, I would
say, well, somebody like John McCain as an
example, you know, previously some people
won't like this, but like William F. Buckley.
OK, Will bunch of William F. Buckley foreign
policy is is horrible, but William F. Buckley
vs. Trump, what?
One of them is a thinker at least.
OK, and we won't agree on a lot of stuff,
but that would be if you said it's got to
be a Republican.
That's the line I'm thinking of dissent.
This is very much in the Trumpy and wing,
completely cartoonish, opened everything like
months into the pandemic.
And Florida has just been a complete and total
mess.
Now, Florida seeing again some of the highest
rates.
They just don't do anything.
I was just there.
It was crazy.
Anti Voxer told me their mom became magnetized
from getting the vaccine.
DeSantis is completely bonkers, but.
He's more competent than Trump, significantly
more competent than Trump, and so when we
look at it, I already said, if it's Trump
Biden, I think Biden's in trouble.
If it's Trump Harris, I think Camille is in
trouble.
The other side of this is, well, if it's DeSantis
instead of Trump, if dissenters can spend
the next couple of years building name recognition,
he is far more competent in that evil genius
sort of way than is Donald Trump.
And I would be very concerned about about
about Ronda Santos.
But for now, Trump remains in control of the
Republican Party, clearly the favorite.
And we're going to continue following how
those numbers change as we get into in particular,
you know, when we get into the midterms.
And that's starting soon.
We're four months from the start of the midterms.
Basically, if Trump's picks don't do well
in twenty twenty two, that could really weaken
Trump.
And we're going to wait and see what happens
on that.